cuba made progress on education
yes i think really
really calm down you oppressed masses
you just don't get how wonderful this is
that's what bernie's done on cuba now
for 50 years
right now in cuba there is a mass
protest movement going on
people are going out and protesting the
cuban communist dictatorship
and the government is clamping down the
president or the dictator rather of cuba
has come out and said they will do
anything they can to preserve the regime
up to and including using violence on
the citizens which they're currently
doing right now
they're naming people beating people and
actually killing people in the streets
and those crickets that you hear right
now are from bernie sanders
because bernie sanders who very nearly
was the democrat nominee for president
twice in 2016
and 2020 long time democratic senator
very long time gadfly he's been in
politics for 50 years
bernie sanders has spoken in very
positive ways
about the cuban dictatorship what i said
is what barack obama said in terms of
cuba
that cuba made progress on education yes
i think really really
do i support their economic policies or
their political policies
of course i don't but you know what else
cuba produces a lot of physicians in
this country
and you know where they go they go to
poor countries around the world
doing a lot of good by and large cuba's
educational system
for a poor country is pretty good when
castro came to power
they did a lot to eliminate illiteracy
in that country
but i remember for some reason i was
being very excited when when fidel
castro made the revolution in cuba and i
was a kid and i remember reading that
and it was just seemed right and
appropriate that poor people were rising
up against
rather ugly rich people i was watching
the debates you remember the famous
nixon
kennedy debates that was the first time
the presidential camp candidates
actually debated
kennedy was saying that nixon was too
soft on communism
usually i'm sufficiently unemotional not
to be sick but i actually got off in the
room and almost left the puke
he almost left to puke he was so upset
because bernie sanders
has supported communism in those terms
right
the guy honeymooned in the soviet union
it doesn't doesn't get more supportive
than that
and now what we're seeing is the people
of cuba
long oppressed by an evil evil system of
government
rising up against that and bernie has
nothing to say
he has nothing to say because he
obviously does not speak
for the cuban people he obviously does
not speak for the oppressed masses i
mean this is the problem
that the marxist revolutionaries had
going back to the days of karl marx
namely that they had all these wonderful
theories for the liberation of the
oppressed masses
but the allegedly oppressed masses
didn't like the theories very much
turned out that the oppressed masses
actually liked their own traditions and
their own countries
and their own families and rituals they
didn't like
the crazy radicalism this is what you're
seeing
right now with marxists in our
valid marxists in our schools and in
other institutions
and you're seeing the actual oppressed
masses in america coming out and
protesting and saying i don't want my
kids being taught this stuff
you're seeing black mothers white
mothers hispanic mothers showing up to
the school board saying
look we don't have a ton of money to
send our kids to private school we don't
have a ton of time to homeschool
we've got to send our kids to these
public schools and you nut
nut bags are coming in and saying that
we've got to
teach our kids critical race theory or
teach our kids critical gender or
radical gender theory and the elites are
saying well no these
these are actually wonderful ideologies
for you they're going to liberate you
they're going to help you
calm down you oppressed masses you just
don't get how wonderful this is
that's what bernie's done on cuba now
for 50 years
and it turns out doesn't work out very
well so he can't he's not going to
continue to defend it right now
he's just got to remain totally silent
as the biden white house by the way has
done until
just recently hey stop i'm really glad
that you enjoyed all that terrible right
wing misinformation that i i just was
spreading you know
recklessly around the internet if you
want even more of that reckless
misinformation
go check out the full episode which is
available now
on this channel it's also available on
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play all over the place
at the michael knowles show and you can
also order my book
chock full of deplorable terrible right
wing misinformation
go get that too that's speechless we'll
see you next time